all right so this talk is the case for
declarative machine learning uh my name
is tristan uh zions and uh to kick
things off uh who am i so that's me
uh look better there than here
um i built one of the first enterprise
data science platforms called sense.io
some of you that are a little bit older
and have gray hair might remember it but
it was one of the sort of early notebook
platforms that were moving everything to
the cloud and you know supporting python
and r and all that sort of stuff
uh that company got acquired by cloudera
and i built the machine learning
platform
for cloudera which is the big data
hadoop
platform
and i'm currently the co-founder of
continual and i say that only because
this this new project is really based on
all the mistakes and pain and suffering
that i that i had from this previous
eight years of my life
um so it's another way of saying i'm
basically a hypocrite uh this is a talk
that i gave in 2018 at the kubernetes
kubecon which is you know how to do you
know machine learning on kubernetes and
why it's so amazing to build pipelines
on kubernetes uh and as you'll see i'll
i'll critique that approach here a
little bit or maybe it's just that uh
you know there's let's
let's go beyond that right let's like
we've done that for five years let's do
something new
um so starting thesis is that ml ops is
drowning in complexity and i think for
anybody who's working in the ml ops
ecosystem hopefully that says well you
know i like my tools but yeah they are
pretty complicated okay like maybe
they're really powerful but they are
pretty complicated
and i think if you if you trace this
back you can i think a good example of
this is five years ago there was a blog
post by uber where they described their
internal machine learning platform the
uber michelangelo platform uh actually
an amazing architectural vision for what
production machine learning looks like
by production machine learning i mean
you know models that are actually
driving businesses to decisions that are
continually maintained right not just a
notebook not just an r d our r d project
and so in their case they wanted to do
that canonical uber thing they wanted to
predict the arrival times that was what
that's what the business you know needed
and they said okay here's the stack that
they built and if you look at this stack
you can see there's about you know seven
different distributed systems here this
is kafka right that's like you know a
whole bunch of nodes that's your storage
uh spark streaming engine there's
cassandra which is your operational
database you know there's a serving
system over here there's a client oh
there you have a data lake or do you
know hadoop cluster you know batch well
hive i guess you know cassandra no you
need different storage hive you know a
whole bunch of things here right a lot a
lot of stuff so incredibly powerful uh
you know if you're an ml engineer it's
kind of fun to build for the first time
i spent my last eight years doing this
kind of stuff uh but you know it's uh
it's not it's it's it's complicated it's
complicated um
you know then you say okay we will move
to the cloud right you know google
solved this aws solved this for us right
so here's aws stack diagram for i just
googled like operational machine
learning for for aws and like this is
the way they told me to do it i'm not
exactly sure how that all works but it
it does i'm sure you i'm sure everybody
here is smart enough to make it work
um i'm actually sure it probably does
work right
um and then oh no we're all startup
folks right so let's do the startup
thing right let's uh actually you know
the aws doesn't invest much in their
individual tools you know best of breed
tools and man they're amazing tools
today you know amazing notebook products
they're amazing experiment trackers i
mean it is remarkable that has certainly
changed there's some awesome individual
tools but again to go to production ml
you know it's quite hard when you think
about continually retraining continual
inference monitoring the whole life
cycle of it
it gets it gets pretty tricky and what
me what it means is you just won't uh
use what what does it mean okay so
what's the end result of this i think
three things one is infrastructure
challenges this infrastructure is just
extremely complicated to set up to
maintain uh it's often disconnected from
the rest of your data and analytics
infrastructure so there's sort of
honestly a developing parallel universe
in the ml world compared to the data and
analytics world we probably have some
people that are more in this modern data
stack world some people are more in the
ml world it's two parallel universes
right so it's just a lot to manage
um they're team challenges the only
people that can do this right are uh you
know you got to be a cloud engineer an
ml engineer a data engineer a data
scientist a you know a
product engineer to actually implement
an end-to-end use case right which just
means it just requires a lot
of time even if you have the skills it
just requires a lot of time right and
you kind of after you've done it once or
twice maybe you don't want to spend the
next three months building that next use
case and then being on the hook and on
call to support it
and then the final one is this
operational challenge right you've got
to get the production anything that's
actually going to impact the business
it's got to be maintained it's got to be
governed it's going to be monitored and
you got to you know you're on the hook
who wants to who wants to be on the hook
for things uh that are that complicated
and of course then you know it seems
like most people leave and start a
startup uh who build ml platforms at a
company so you know you actually got to
join somebody else's uh ml platform and
support somebody else's ml model so
it's just less fun right not super fun
okay
um
so the question is is there a better way
that way has been the sort of the status
quo away for the last five five six
seven years um everybody's building it
it's extremely powerful it's i guess
it's you could say it's it's proven um
but the question is is there another way
and i want to say there is another way
uh we've seen this problem before and
we've actually fixed it in other domains
so and remarkably actually sandy i don't
know if sandy's here but he gave it he's
got almost exactly similar slides
yesterday at the dagster sandy gave us
similar slides of the dax to talk so
shout out to that it's amazing that we
converged on the same slides without
seeing each other so
what would it mean it's been solved in
the in in other domains so think about
infrastructure we used to manage
infrastructure with bash scripts we'd
provision things we'd like you know call
aws apis we had apis but we managed it
with bash scripts who does that anymore
right we use terraform right or we use
polumi we use something that has moved
from this like pipeline jungle world to
some sort of declarative specification
here with terraform think about data
right you might remember you know we all
got excited about mapreduce we wrote all
these crazy uh mapreduce jobs now what's
the new reality we're back to sql right
we're back to a declarative high level
language that allows us to do to to do
uh analytics or if you want to go beyond
sql you know go and use daxter even
daxter is moving to a declarative sort
of way to manage data assets and
allowing you to have the flexibility of
code or python to do it but still
automating as much as we can and
removing it
if we think about
ui frameworks to go a little bit further
afield right we used to all build uis
you know jquery was oh my god it's
standardized the dom for those who are
uui people
uh and then what do we do we did we use
react right top down state everything's
a common component don't have to worry
about how the dom gets updated right
it's just a declarative way to build
build you build ui it doesn't mean it's
code free right doesn't mean it's no
code point click everything but it's
saying let's get rid of all the
incidental complexity that we don't have
to care about we don't that's not
substantive to the problem at hand which
is doing a building a ui or whatever it
is let's get rid of it right build a
higher level of abstraction if we can
find one
so
that's the solution it seems in many
domains is to find the right higher
level abstraction in some ways that the
future of technology always has been
moving up up the stack right from you
know hardware to higher level software
abstractions right garbage collection et
cetera now declarative declarative
systems
so the question i have for everybody is
you know is there a similar way is there
something similar that we can do with
respect to ml whatever domain of ml that
you might be working on and the work
what we're working on at continual is to
enable operational ml is there a way to
find a higher level abstraction that
simplifies this that democratizes it
that makes it easier to put into the
business
and okay is there so what is i think
first thing to say is well what is
operational ml like how do we decompose
this can we find a uh you know a pattern
here
well so the standard answer is if you
actually know what your how this works
is it's basically pipelines right
there's all these pipeline jungles to
maintain all these things to maintain
models monitor models retrain models uh
rescore models et cetera
that doesn't seem like a you know it
works but that doesn't seem necessarily
like the right approach right that's
kind of the imperative approach so i
want to submit that there are really two
things um there's one thing with respect
to ml and there's another thing
with respect to operational side of the
things so the first thing with respect
to ml is the task at the very high level
we need to describe the task what are we
trying to predict what are we trying to
achieve not the algorithm or how we're
going to do it but the task right
and there are if you start to squint
carefully at where the state of the art
is going with respect to ml a very high
way to think about tasks as inputs okay
what are going into your predictive
models and we're coming out of the on
those models and you can think of the
different types so think about think
about classification so here i have a
diagram this is from this ludvik project
which is super interesting a diagram
where i have a bunch of input types
going to output types um and we have uh
you know let's say text to text well
that's you know open ai's whole business
model right there that's machine
translation right so if you had text in
text out that's machine translations if
you had a categorical and a number going
to a number that's regression if you add
category to a number to go into a
category that's classification right if
you have time series sequence or time
series sequence that's time series
forecasting image to a category that's
image classification image plus text to
text is image question answering okay
a sequence and a sequence uh to a
sequence can actually be reinforcement
learning you can actually have a
sequence of states a sequence of rewards
conditioning on the rewards and then
generating the sequence of actions that
you're doing so you could actually play
chess with this a bunch of papers
actually this year about this how you
can think about reinforcement learning
as a sequence problem so the point is
this is all this is is input types
semantic input types rich input types
you might need a broader range of types
mapped to output types and you can
describe an incredible range of ml
problems and who cares the algorithms is
it deep learning is it xg boost what the
internal system can automate that figure
that out right maybe this is all should
be done with one kind of new transformer
model there's incredible convergence or
maybe we should just do automl try a
whole bunch of things see what works
okay
the next thing is well that's just the
model what about operational we need to
think we're going to maintain these
model monitors what do we actually need
to know so that i would say we need
policies we just need we just need a few
different policies things like you know
and here's a screenshot from continual
where it's our ui building the ui the
policies in the ui we support different
ways to do this
and we have okay we're going to train
this model monthly we're going to
promote the latest model or the best
model we're going to manually go in
there and promote the model we're going
to rescore their model and kind of
update the predictions in our world in
the data warehouse as you'll see we'll
do that every night right we're trying
to update the churn and maintain the
probability a customer will churn or how
much they'll spend or what your
inventory level will be we just set some
policies and so we just need tasks and
policies what else do we need why isn't
everything else just uh you know
automatic and taken care of for our
platforms
so that leads to continual right this is
a startup i guess this lightning talks
is kind of startup oriented so what are
we doing at continual so we're trying to
take this desire for a building a higher
level abstraction for ml uh and we're
bringing it to the modern data stack so
continual continuous we're building
operational ai for the modern data stack
there's three fundamental things that
we're doing so the first thing is that
we're uh uh we're data we were data
centric but more importantly we're data
warehouse centric so we believe that the
future of data lives in the data
warehouse we both read the data from the
data warehouse and write the predictions
back to the data warehouse so you can
think of us as continually maintaining
uh predictions and enriching your data
warehouse with predictions
two to this talk we have a declarative
workflow right there's no pipe there's
no infrastructure there's no pipelines
there's no models
everything can be done through a
declarative data first specification and
i'll show you exactly what that means in
a second
i have no idea what my time is here
because there's no timer um and we're
three minutes okay uh and we're when
we're operationally focused in that
sense in that sense everything that you
that we build in continual is maintained
we maintain the models and we maintain
the predictions and so what does this
look like more specifically so in the
data warehouse dbt is very popular and
so what we want to do is we want to
enable different types of users people
that want to use a ui people that want
to use dbt people that come from want to
use yaml people that want to use python
and declare things in python so let's
imagine that we're the dbt user what
does this look like
well the first concept we have is the
feature set this is our inputs what are
the inputs to your predictive models
what do you know about your customers
for instance what how active have they
been on your website how much have they
bought these are the inputs to your
predictive models so we say the first
thing you need to do is register in the
system in a declarative way the features
from the data setting in your data
warehouse now if you're using dbt this
looks very familiar you have a sql query
this is a dbt this is the way dbt works
it's dbt
sql query plus dbt annotations if you
want to think of it as the yaml file
it's exactly the same thing if you want
to think about a python function you
could do that with a bunch of you know
inputs or json or whatever you have
we augment it with a couple things we
say that there's an entity this query
customer id month feature feature one
feature two from this customer activity
table relates to my customer i need some
semantic information it's about my
customer not just saying my index my
customer id references my customer then
there's a time index it's super
important for machine learning platform
for machine learning use cases to take
very careful attention to time and so
here we have a time index which is
saying that this feature is for this
particular moment in time what did i
know about the customer at this
particular moment in time so that when i
predict whether they're going to churn
i'm using the right information that i
had i'm not leaking information right so
we we register this with our system now
we have features that we can use in a
lot of predictive models
second thing we now do is we now
actually need to build something that's
predictive okay for that we need the
outputs right what are we trying to
predict right so that the ground truth
that we're going to try to predict and
it gets a little bit more complicated in
terms of the metadata but from the query
you just have the customer id the month
and the churn in this case it's whether
the customer is going to churn the next
month then you can define again a little
bit of extra metadata the index and the
the time index just so you have that
link that join essentially the target
what are you trying to predict right uh
and then here we have a foreign key
reference essentially that this customer
id column references this so that we can
join in the right information you at the
right point in time so with a point in
time correct join so we don't have data
leakage we can join this in and a little
bit of policy around how we want to
maintain this
from this we should be able to in my
view we should be able to drive a
production ml system that's continually
maintained continually updated and
that's what happens in continual so
you know this is the model that you get
like basically this is a visual
representation of what i just showed you
it's actually from the product
if you're using the cli and not the ui
you and you're a dbt user you'd run dbt
run which generates your you know views
in snowflake and then you run continual
run which generates a number of tables
and views inside your data warehouse
where all of your predictions are going
to live and be continually maintained
right from that with nothing else okay
what happens when you do continual run
is we like terraform go and figure out
what needs to happen we figure out do we
need to create some tables and views in
your data warehouse do we need to train
somebody else we want to profile things
do we want to run a prediction and
update the predictions in your data
warehouse we can figure all of that out
from that declarative specification so
here we're create we're creating some
views we're running a bunch of models
we're looking at the particular model
type which in this case was
classification uh and so we realized
that we tried a whole bunch of 11
different experiments we got this model
we promoted a model and we predicted it
this is like a terraform apply plan if
you if you if you if you think of if
you're from that world
you know here's the example of us hey
we're doing classification let's just
try a whole bunch of models right so
automl let's try this and hey if you
want to have drop down and extend it
fine extend it right but that shouldn't
be the aspiration right so you get 97
accuracy again with almost no work
and then of course it's got to be in
production it's got to be monitored
right otherwise you're not having an
impact and so again that all i did was
add some schedules and now the model is
continually maintained retrained
reinforced we get historical performance
current performance a whole bunch of
other stuff drift etc
so
here you are let's build more
declarative ml systems regardless of the
domain you have uh it's
powers your whole data team it reduces
the operational burden of ml and it's
just way way more fun so
continual.ai if you want to check it out
[Applause]